but i would love to uh
return to genghis khan and get your
thoughts about
like i have so many mixed feelings about
whether he is evil or not
whether the violence that he
brought to the world had ultimately the
fact that it had
maybe kind of uh like dan carlin
describes
cleansed the landscape it's like a reset
for the world through violence
had ultimately
a progressive effect on human
civilization
even though in the short term it led to
massive you could say suffering
i don't know what to make of that man
what uh what are your thoughts on
jenkins gone
um i think it's always difficult to look
at a historical figure
and their actions of their time through
a modern day lens
because it's very it's easy for us to
um kind of you know impugn their
achievements and the things that they
did
and say oh well you know what he did was
wrong
well of course that can be true but a
lot of times
we don't actually have any real good
context or concept of
the the times they were living in and
what really was deemed wrong and what
really wasn't we're looking at it
through a very cushy modern lens
that being said from what i've read
about genghis khan
uh yeah he was a violent dude but also
he gave you an option
he when he when he got to a village he
said look
i'm gonna we're gonna you have a choice
you can come with us
or you can run and you know he gave them
an option to join
uh his legion of fighters who he took
very good care of you know he was the
the first military leader uh to pay his
soldiers families when they died
and he did that based on the the booty
that they got when they
raided a village he took that money he
took his share and they divided that up
amongst the soldiers and then the
soldiers families
i think he also is credited with uh
first like horseback male roots or
something like that right
isn't he the godfather of the modern
postal system or something
something like that yeah he's the bernie
sanders of the uh
oh the mongol empire i do think the
the offering of surrender is an
interesting one because um
it's interesting like as a thought
experiment whether you would sacrifice
your way of
like the pride of nations or the
nationalism pride of your country
whether you're willing to give that up
uh for uh you know to survive
it depends on who depends on you if you
have a
if you have a family and like young kids
and stuff like that i think your
your obligation is primarily to them and
therefore
surrender has to be something that you
consider in that in that moment
in time so that you can uh take care of
those people
if you're a man alone and you've got
like all these principles and all this
other stuff and you just don't
you're not down with what genghis khan
is doing and what he's selling
yeah try and escape do your thing and
just know that you know what wait's on
the other side of that for you
potentially
but i think if there's someone else out
there that depends on you
your obligation should be to them it
feels like
historically people value principles
more than life
in this weight of like what do i value
more the principles i hold versus
survival
it seems that now we don't value
principles as much
your principles could be also religion
it could be your values whatever
we're okay sort of sacrificing those for
to preserve our survival and that
applies in all forms like
actual survival or like on
social media like preserving your
reputation all those kinds of things
it seems like we and
especially in america value individual
life that death is somehow a really bad
thing
as opposed to saying sacrificing your
principles is a very bad thing and
everybody dies
and it's okay to die as what's horrible
is to sacrifice your principles of who
you are
just to live another day i think a big
problem is people don't really even know
what their principles are anymore
people you know um social media
and just the way that we live nowadays
where we're separated from the human
contact like this like we're not
you're not contacting people in a
community anymore you're not
whether you're religious or not like
you're not you're not congregating at a
church
you're not part of a parish like you
would be like in you know down south
you're not part of that community
anymore and so
it's difficult to figure out what your
principles and values are because you're
constantly jumping from one bucket to
the next
uh online and you don't get a lot of
like
direct like reasonable feedback from
people
you just get [ __ ] feedback like oh
you don't believe this well you're a
jerk
i think the hard thing currently is
having the integrity and character to
stick by principles one under
i don't want to equate murder of in the
genghis khan times
to uh social media cancel culture
but it certainly doesn't feel good when
people are attacking on social media
and it does take a lot of integrity to
uh
without anger without emotion without
without being without mocking others or
attacking others unfairly
standing by the ideas you hold
or in another way
uh standing by your friends standing by
this
little group like loyalty of
the people that you know are good people
i find that uh in
in cancel culture one of the sad things
is whenever somebody gets quote-unquote
cancelled
everybody just gets all their friends
become really quiet
and don't defend them or worse
i mean quiet is at least understandable
they kind of
signal that they throw them under the
bus i guess
uh is one way to put it and that that's
something i think about
a lot because from coming for me it's
like
i i hold an ethic i don't know if others
hold this ethic maybe it's
this like russian mobster ethic of like
you should help your friends bury the
body
you shouldn't criticize your friends for
committing the murder
like there are certain levels of like
you know
yeah you have that discussion after you
bury the body
that like maybe you shouldn't have done
that murder thing right
uh i don't know you know i understand
that that's a problematic
um what's with the terminology
that's a problematic ethical framework
within which to operate but
at the same time it feels like what else
do we have in this world
except the brotherhood the sisterhood
the love we have for a very small
community
but perhaps that's the wrong way of
thinking perhaps the 21st century would
be
defined uh by the dissipation of this
community of this loyalty concept
no we're all just individuals i think
you're right and i think you have to
have some sort of core
framework of principles and beliefs that
you operate on
and i think when i was what i was
referencing is a little bit
different and but to speak to your point
you you need a framework
of core principles on which you can then
base a lot of your other decisions like
i believe these three things to be true
whatever they are
and that will help inform other
decisions you make in your life
as far as how you treat your friends
i've got i've got probably three friends
that
if they called me right now and said
let's bury the body sorry lex i gotta go
there are other people in my life that
if they said uh hey we've got to go bury
the body
i would say who is this
you know yeah so i think it it depends
on the relationship
i want to that's a good it's a really
good measure i would love to have i
would love
that to be in your profile people put
like pronouns i would love to put like
uh honestly like objectively not
self-report but
objective how many people in your life
if they committed murder you would not
ask any questions and you would help
them
hide the body right like i would love to
know that number for people
yeah and and i think it's a weird thing
too because you think right away like
okay
it must be the group of people that are
the closest to you that's who you're
first thinking of right
but obviously for like my best friend i
would do it no question about it
but i've got other people that are close
to me that
are close to me in other ways and i
probably wouldn't do that only because i
don't think they do it for me
yeah and and that is a consideration um
so i guess is the principle there then
that
you do for your friends what you think
they would do for you is that the
underlying principle
or do you just have a blind loyalty to
you know
people in your life for different
reasons i got people that are not on my
inner circle
that i probably wouldn't help change a
tire
to in the morning if they're on the
highway but if they called me and said
hey we got to bury the body
i might show up for that it's just these
weird different connections yeah it's
fascinating yeah i have uh
close friends that like i probably be
exactly the tyre is a good example would
be like can't you find somebody else to
do this
i think part of that is just this leap
of faith into like giving yourself
to the other person that
uh creates a deep connection that makes
life
fulfilling like meaningful
that doesn't exist if you don't take
that leap i mean it's not about the
murder we're sort of focusing
i think that's a i think you have to uh
what does it cross that bridge when you
get there i'm not exactly sure is this
just the thought experiment
but it's it's i think about that a lot
especially these covet times
and as like people become more and more
isolated and separated from each other
like how important is it to have those
deep deep connections to other humans
i think especially like what you're
talking about there have you ever seen
the movie the town
there's a great line in the movie where
one of the main characters walks into
his friend's house
and he says i need your help
we're gonna go hurt some people and you
can never ask me about it again
and the friend looks up and he says
whose car we taking
that that is the type of person you need
in your life and the people
like there are people that will walk
through that door and say that to you
and you drop everything you're doing and
then there's a people that walk through
your door and you're like
you know what i got a hot pocket in the
microwave
i'm a little bit i'm a little bit tied
up right now but i'd love to help you
out but yeah you know
i don't want to do that and you don't
have that that deep connection with
those people
you